- [David] Hello,
grammarians, hello, Rosie.
- [Rosie] Hi, David.
- [David] So today we're gonna talk
about a special kind of
dependent clause, which again,
is a kind of clause
that can't be a sentence
on its own called a relative clause.
So a relative clause is a dependent clause
that starts with a relative pronoun
So okay, so a relative pronoun is a word
like who or that or
which or whose or where
that like any pronoun, substitutes in
for another part of the sentence.
So for example, Harry
Potter is also known as.
- [Rosie] The boy who lived.
- [David] The boy who lived.
- [Rosie] Is that Dumbledore?
- [David] Yeah, that's my Dumbledore.
- [Rosie] I like it.
- [David] Thank you.
You can see in this little
snippet who is subbing in
for the boy, right, so it is behaving
like a pronoun, but a relative pronoun,
and so we've got this
thing here, who lived.
The boy lived, on its
own, could be a sentence,
but who lived cannot be.
- [Rosie] Well who lived
is describing the boy.
- [David] So right now,
all of this together is
just a noun phrase, but who lived within
this noun phrase is a relative clause.
So, we need to find a
store that sells the new
Willamette cold brew coffee ice cream.
- [Rosie] I've heard it's really good.
- [David] So all of this
together is a sentence.
This is definitely a sentence
We need to find a store that
sells the new Willamette
cold brew coffee ice cream.
Like, indisputably, that is a sentence.
We have our subject, we.
We have our verb, need,
and then the object
of need is to find a store
that sells the new Willamette
cold brew coffee ice cream.
But, we're focusing on
this yellow part here,
so that is substituting in for a store,
that's what that relative
pronoun is representing.
And then we have that sells the new,
so we've got store that sells, right?
So that is our subject here.
Sells is the verb
The new Willamette cold
brew coffee ice cream
is the object of sells, and
everything in yellow here,
all this yellow text,
is our relative clause.
It cannot stand on its own as a sentence.
You could not just have that
sells the new Willamette
cold brew coffee ice cream.
On its own, that doesn't work
because the very presence
of this relative pronoun
requires more stuff to go on.
Well, let's make things a
little more complicated.
The woman who always wore a red hat came
into the cafe every Sunday.
So this sentence contains
a relative clause
right there in the middle of it,
who always wore a red hat.
All right, so we've
got who substituting in
for the woman and that's the subject
of the verb phrase wore
a red hat, but again,
this could not be a sentence on its own.
Now the challenge here
is when you see sentences
like this in the wild,
then you see sentences
like these in the exercises,
they're not gonna be
differentiated for your convenience
with two different colors, so
you have to be very careful
to figure out where this
dependent clause begins and ends.
So you can parse, so you can
make sense of this sentence,
in order to make it work.
So really what is this
sentence actually saying,
just on a base level?
- [Rosie] The woman came into the cafe.
- [David] Right, and so everything
else, this every Sunday,
or who always wore a red
had, that is kinda extra,
and so it's your job as a
writer, reader and editor
of text, as someone who is working
with the English
language, to puzzle it out
and separate the sentence
into its components.
- [Rosie] Right, this is a
who always wore a red hat
is a description of the woman.
- [David] Right.
- [Rosie] Then we move on
to the verb, the action
of the sentence, what is she
doing, she came into the cafe,
so that's not part of
that relative clause.
The relative clause is just,
in this case, providing
some description of the woman.
- [David] Right, so use
your best sense because yes,
it is possible that the
red hat could be the thing
that comes into the cafe every Sunday,
but it's more likely
that that hat is attached
to the woman that was referenced earlier.
- [Rosie] Right.
- [David] So, that is a relative clause.
You can learn anything.
David out.
- [Rosie] Rosie out.